a 25 year old woman named Emily let's
who's an abortion counselor from New
Jersey she filmed herself having an
abortion and this thing has been blowing
up and you might have seen it already
we're gonna show you just a little bit
of it I just want to share my story to
show women that there is such thing as a
positive abortion story
[Music]
yeah exactly
[Music]
okay so obviously she was trying to show
a positive abortion story and she's
obviously pro-abortion she's an abortion
counselor I believe a woman has a right
to choose and I have no right to tell a
woman what to do with her own body but
after watching this I was really kind of
conflicted if this sorta helps the cause
of abortion or not because by showing
something that clinical it actually felt
a little weird to me it really did what
do you think I mean okay I like it
personally I think my very first
response when I watched this was like I
don't care but I don't think I'm the
audience for this for this story i I've
never had an abortion but like you I'm
pro-choice I have friends who have had
abortions and I don't think that I need
a YouTube video to understand the
process but that's me I would research
it in different ways I think if I were
faced with that difficult let's be
honestly she may have not been going to
the kerrick's anomie exactly I'm not you
know but my second response when I saw
this video was like you know if like
it's not well done that's like I think
that that was my problem she's trying to
force with the music and like oh it's a
positive experience it's like okay it's
it's a personal experience yeah it's an
experience that could have positive
often does have positive ramifications
in somebody's life down the line but I
don't know if having an outpatient
procedure is like you know something
that needs violin music behind it it
just you're right it puts a bad taste in
your mouth a little bit and I think more
than anything all this video is really
going to do is going to polarize people
if you look at where it was posted the
article where I first read it from was
on a conservative site and the vitriol
in the comment section was like I mean
granted she must have known that was
gonna happen I don't blame her I think
that you know she has the right to make
this kind of statement and honestly
maybe if she did touch one or two young
women who were like I want to do this
but I'm afraid I think that it's gonna
hurt I think it's gonna you know ruin my
life and they watch that they go oh
maybe it's not that bad I actually do
have an option you know well and you're
totally right about strengthening the
other side thing because once this thing
got posted on Drudge then it goes across
the right-wing blogosphere and everyone
starts
that's it do you generally agree with
that I mean I generally do I think I
feel bad because you're right it's get
posted on a conservative website the
comments were so hateful towards her
they said that she got pregnant on
purpose so that she could do this and
get all this attention which is just
because we love having abortion really
touchy subject and like I almost try to
avoid saying that I'm pro-abortion and
say that I'm pro-choice because no one
wants me pro-abortion like you how
abortions are awesome but how many
people I think that like it's it's it's
something that most women use as a form
of birth control because it's somehow
easier it's somehow easier to just not
think about it get laid what the [ __ ]
ever I'll just take care of the baby
it's like no woman wants to do that it
can't be comfortable and it is emotional
for most people there's a lot of medical
problems sometimes people can't get
pregnant after having an abortion
there's a lot of serious consequences
with it and it can be psychologically
detrimental which is something that I
think the one of the biggest reasons why
I didn't like this video is because
she's just so like happy the whole time
and that's good because like you said
it's important to show girls who've
already made the choice to have an
abortion that it's not going to hurt you
know it's not going to be as horrible as
they might think it could be and it kind
of gives them some reassurance but at
the same time it's kind of like almost
encouraging in a way right so it sounds
like you're both agree that her idea was
good here but that the way they produce
this with the music and you know her
like she was going so far out of her way
to make it seem like it was okay but
also you know we don't see the clinical
things it sort of reminded me of like
the death penalty when we don't see
these people being put to death I'm
against the death penalty anyway but
like if we don't see it we don't know
what's going on and by seeing her laying
there it felt much more human it
actually was making me rethink my
position a little bit I'm still
pro-choice I mean that that's kind of
why my first reaction was just like the
production values are so terrible I feel
like if it had been produced a little
bit differently
like if if she had you know edited
things a little bit differently shown it
looked like she selectively edited to
only show the parts where she was the
most comfortable she never once said
like okay this part it's a little income
pastured I'm past it if it had felt a
little more real to me
because I I do kind of like the idea
though that we were in that room with
her experiencing it with her and she was
sharing that intimate moment so that
people would on
stand like if I can do it and you're
afraid to do it but you know you need to
do it you can do it too
but it was almost forced in this weird
kind of positive kumbaya bias like you
said yes
unreal unrealistic just no one's gonna
be that excited and that happy to go
through this process I feel like it
should have showed both sides right and
of course you know she I'm not saying
she got pregnant I'm not going on to say
she got pregnant to do this video but
obviously her allegiances are where they
are because an abortion Hauser's so she
wanted to spin it in in a certain light
what do you guys make of the men
basically that try to tell you what to
do with your bodies because it's pretty
much all men or a huge percentage of men
that that are always voting on abortion
and and writing read legislation all of
that and I'm always fascinated by it
because I literally cannot understand
how someone who does not have the body
parts can tell you what to do with your
body parts yeah I totally agree there
needs to be more women in legislation so
that kind of thing doesn't happen but I
don't want to be too one-sided because I
feel like certain women who are in
relationships have abortions without
telling their significant other and that
can be kind of a gray area I think where
you might need to actually talk to the
father I are you thinking they should
have some sort of like force you know I
don't think iteration I don't think so
but I just feel like to say that you
know men have no say and they shouldn't
even be able to give me their opinion on
it I think that's going a little too far
I mean of course I think men should be
able to give you their opinion yeah
we're talking about the people that are
voting yeah I mean but I personally feel
very strongly that until a baby is born
like it's it's a women's health issue
and a women's health issue alone until
in this you know this organism is viable
on its own what we're really talking
about is a medical condition see as a
medical condition for a woman yeah and
it's a choice that she is deciding to
make the same way that she can make a
choice about the best treatment option
for her cancer the same way that she can
make a choice about you know whether or
not she wants to elect to have certain
surgeries and yes I think that having
outside perspectives is helpful I hope
that if you're you're only lucky enough
to be in a situation where there is a
man in your life I was willing to give
you his opinion about the situation
because many
times when a woman is faced with the
decision of having an abortion she's on
her [ __ ] own and that's even more
difficult but it's her choice
fundamentally it is her choice and
nobody has a right whether we're talking
about legislators or we're talking about
people with personal relationships to
tell a woman what she can and can't do
with her own pregnancy because until
that baby is born it is a women's health
a medical issue
so you're saying until that baby is born
do you guys have a cut-off is there a
cut-off point because that's the other
debate you know is it the the two
trimesters is it because it seems to me
that eight if you were to say eight
months well that baby probably could
live I think it's silly to draw a line
to be honest I think it's silly to draw
a line like obviously when the baby is
born
then there are certain legal issues that
you can't argue with but before then I
feel like it's an individual's
you know perspective on the situation
and that's why I'm pro-choice because my
opinion on that might not be the same as
somebody else's opinion on that and I
recognize that so I personally don't
think I could go through with having an
abortion but that has nothing to do with
my you know willingness to vote on
whether or not somebody else can you
know I'm not gonna be pushy I mean
obviously there are legal issues that
you know in a perfect world we don't
often think about so sure maybe there's
a woman who's eight-and-a-half months
pregnant she's abusing drugs and alcohol
the courts want to be able to say right
you're abusing a life inside of you and
we should be able to force you to maybe
stop doing that we should be able to
force you to have the child instead of
Bulba and that's where things start to
get really touchy and really you know
touch-and-go like I said but it's a
complicated topic I think but the
problem most of the time when it comes
to this kind of legislation is not
motivated by those specific situations I
think this legislation is generally
motivated by religious bias and and
there are people who go to the extreme
that they'll say that like the actual
seed the actual sperm is you know
ordained by God and that that shouldn't
even be spilled so I think that I'm
pretty sure my sermon but so final
thought on this is is this you know I
was thinking this putting this type of
thing on you too
really is such a 2014 thing is there
something very freeing happening in the
digital sphere that we can put this
stuff out there and that whether it's
whether it's good or bad whether we
watch this and whether it's
strengthening the other side or not or
whether it's really affect you know
changing anyone's mind that's going to
be more pro-choice this is all good
though just the information right yeah I
think that overall it's a positive thing
just because it does give that comfort
to girls who've decided to have an
abortion but I do see how it can really
be a lightning rod for the opposite side
yeah and that's what frustrates me the
most because religious people are the
ones who are saying don't masturbate
don't use condoms don't take birth
control and then they want to legislate
against abortions it's like well maybe
if you were a little bit more
open-minded about prevention it's it's
very cool that we're living in a world
right now where free speech is is kind
of helped by multimedia and by the fact
that we can use something as simple as
the the camera on our phone to produce a
video and to tell a message in a much
more compelling way than just standing
outside and hoping that people will
gather around us to hear what we have to
say and we at least have that freedom on
the internet for a little while longer
although net neutrality was struck down
which we've also talked about a thousand
times so you know good luck to us all
[Music]